the most fundamental skill that we have
for understanding all of these graphs
right it's a kind of slow skill but it's
useful because you can know almost
nothing about something and still sort
of work out something okay and you're
gonna see this will come up again and
again when we look at these other we
don't color shapes because they're all
different
okay and the skill is when you already
know which is plotting points now
plenty points is where you draw up a
table like this okay and you say well
okay let's just see what happens and
then see if we can join the dots okay so
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
try some different Y values and some
different X values okay but why not is
I'm gonna try out our 0 1 & 2 they're
kind of a standard place to start
okay now let's think about this the way
you fill out a table of values you
should say well okay I'm gonna try and
see what happens if y is equal to 0 I'll
see what happens to X okay so I come
over to my equation now hold on hold on
we're gonna get to the motor side y
equal 0 wait away when we put that into
this equation this there's no y in there
this is that there's nowhere for me to
put the 0 right as opposed to questions
like this right I've got lies here I
could for y equal 0 into there and I'd
get a number right or I can put the key
okay over here but there are no why's
here and there's not meant to be and you
can't just put one there because you
want to you get something different
there's no wine right X X doesn't care
about what Y is it's gonna be minus 100
right you see that let X equal minus
it's telling you I'm equal to minus
hundred well you change the value of y
what happens what happens to X he
doesn't care him he's still by design
Lord because that one why cuz what it
doesn't it's got nowhere to go into
there's no why to substitute it in so
therefore and this is this is safer why
it goes to next doesn't care he's like
yeah just whatever man okay so I can
take these three points I don't really
need three even good right and I can
make coordinate seven this one is minus
100 zero this one will be minus 101 and
in this last one will be minus 102 now I
can join these up I can draw them right
scales gonna be a bit funny cuz they're
number but you know let's call that
minus 100 over there okay there's - I'm
good 0-100 one would just be a bit high
up and - under two would just be a bit
higher than that and I could keep on
going up and I could keep going down I'm
just gonna get this just well they're
all straight lines this is a vertical
straight okay so it's parallel to the
y-axis okay
now even though they don't ask this
question I'm just gonna pose a simple
comparison right instead of x equals
minus 100 what if the question I gave
you was y equals 50 think about that one
thing okay it's instead of an X I've got
a Y right where is it gonna go when you
when you try to do this when you plot
some values right plus the points
no no I mean a whole new equation which
means a whole new graph just go well
okay you're gonna get a fight if I draw
a table values right yeah I'm gonna get
say X equal zero Y I'll be 50 because he
doesn't care
i'ma do x equals 1 and y is still gonna
be 50 because he doesn't care right and
then - and you still gotta meet
different you get the picture right so
now when I join up all of these I will
get as Britney says aligned by this
it'll be horizontal instead of vertical